The Joe Rogan Experience like one of the
greatest examples is happening right now
is this massive protest in France
massive protest in France nine million
people on the street literally upset
about the social security change yes
macron in France takes his [__]
eighty thousand dollar watch off under
the table while he's talking to people
about tightening up and about how you
know about how you know this has to be
done like it's the guy's wearing a
[__] we'll find out what watch he was
wearing because you're a watch head you
would like this but the fact that this
dork thought it was a good move to take
his [__] watch off under the table
and then there's the the protest in
Israel no Miss protests in Israel
millions of people on the streets and
you're not hearing a [__] peep about
it you know all it is is like January
6th January 6th did you see what they
did January
Trump is coming back but January 6th
looms large how about the fact that the
guy who's the president right now can't
form a [__] sentence he makes up
words and stumbles through things and no
one says a goddamn thing about it
what watch was you wearing
France France said that this is the cost
of the watch is fake news
and trying to buy it used
so it's not 80 000. if you're buying it
it's gonna cost more sometimes right it
depends on the watch right yeah most of
the time now
yeah isn't that weird people like uh
used watches
well I think it's just that the watch
the you know the big you know the big
four right yeah so what is that I don't
know if you can tell beautiful watch I
mean it's hard to tell very thin it's a
very thin watch
uh removes luxury watch during interview
so does it say what kind of watch some
wrongly claimed it was worth up to 80
000 pounds or eighty six thousand
dollars
but uh Elise Palace said this was not
correct what's the [__] watch tell me
what the watch is you criminals so he
took the watch off
he he took the watch off during his
interview about his con the
controversial pension changes that is
[__] hilarious what a douchebag there
you go oh here it is oh it's a bell and
Ross yeah it's no way it's that much
that's not my much which is personalized
with a coat of arms okay
um let's do that let's um Bell and Ross
brv192 I don't think that's like that's
like a ten thousand dollar watch if I
had a guess well that's all right
that one says 400 200.
does that same watch it looks different
brv192 click on that that's also
possible they're just telling you that's
what the watch is yeah that's not the
same watch okay that's definitely not
the same one I think it was blue that's
it right there yeah but but is that it
is that the same thing not necessarily
yeah not necessarily just definitely not
with that coat of arms let me see that
image again go back to that so I'm
looking at that and then scroll down no
no yeah there you go maybe
that might be the watch but what I'm
looking at then why would you take it
off I'm looking at those circles go back
to that image please
I'm looking at those is that maybe
doesn't look like there's uh something
at the bottom of it yeah yeah wouldn't
it be funny if it was a tourbillon
right let's explain tourbillons to
people uh it's a device that basically
allows for completely equal rotation of
the gears of the watch independent of
the angle of the wrist yeah people don't
understand that a watch like what I'm
I'm wearing an Omega Seamaster uh it's
very accurate but it's more accurate in
certain positions in terms of like how
the the mechanical
winding of the watch works and the
tourbillon doesn't matter where you're
at it's perfect I saw a grand Seiko
tourbillon that was like a quarter of a
million dollars that looks like the same
watch right yeah okay that is probably
the watch so yeah that is a lie then
because that's like a
that's like a two thousand dollar watch
that looks like the watch doesn't it
yeah it just says yeah that's Bell and
Ross something else right there yeah
that's it that's a bell and Ross yeah
that's it so it's like a two thousand
dollar watch it's a very nice watch but
it's you know it's not an 80 000 watch
I took mine it's still funny that he
took it off you took yours off
well you weren't looking I took them I
remember the table what do you wear a
Speedmaster Speedy yeah that's hilarious
that he did that though like why would
he do that that's a dumb move because
that's not even that expensive a watch
it's a nice watch but
but it draws more attention when you
take it off it shows what a [__] is
he's like oh take this watch off